when you see some of the monsters and
entities they try to contain it's easy
to think of the scp foundation as the
good guys and granted when you observe
the magnitude of threats like the
scarlet king it's hard for anyone to not
look like a downright moral paragon in
comparison but the foundation aren't
always knights in shining armor
sometimes they themselves have committed
horrific atrocities in order to keep
their supernatural subjects under wraps
and keep the rest of us safe from
anomalous terror nowhere is that more
clear than a deadly incident that
occurred in 2010 the foundation had been
aware of the slow burn sloth for decades
and many believe that the entity has
existed for as long as human beings have
consumed visual media movies tv webpages
and even print media like books and
magazines are vulnerable technically
speaking the name scp-2774
refers to whatever visual medium is
currently holding the true entity known
as scp-2774-a
thankfully
scp-2774-a has never made it onto the
internet where it could do truly
catastrophic damage but the foundation
has prepared for that possibility
they've invented a software program web
crawler a03 g32 designed to constantly
monitor all forms of online visual media
for an appearance of scp-2774-a
so what is scp-2774-a
what could possibly be so scary that
even a picture of it leaking onto the
internet could potentially lead to the
collapse of human civilization simply
put scp-2774-a
is this image of an unknown humanoid
entity in a bizarre sloth costume while
this picture may seem harmless that's
only because it's black and white and
any red or green hues have been
neutralized from the image anyone who
isn't red green colorblind and somehow
accidentally sees the true version of
scp-2774-a
has a fate far worse than death in store
for them this is the same fate that
would befall almost the entire
population of the northern canadian town
of harper ridge in 2010. the residents
of this small township were waking up
and going about their morning some were
getting ready for work others enjoying a
leisurely breakfast in front of the
television set all of those affected had
unknowingly made the deadly mistake of
watching the local news that morning
while the anchor droned on about some
local economic statistics and delivered
a dry advertisement for an upcoming town
festival the familiar image of something
in the sloth costume appeared briefly on
the set behind him most of the harper
ridge residents who viewed the broadcast
didn't even notice the sloth but in that
fateful instant almost every single one
of them was doomed the slow burn sloth
doesn't always affect everyone who sees
it foundation scientists have found that
it generally only affects 40 of people
exposed to it and doesn't affect those
suffering from colorblindness at all
however one of the more frightening
details about the sloth which is
classified as a memetic image scp for
its ability to spread and appear
randomly almost anywhere is that it
grows more powerful and more contagious
with every living victim it affects
after claiming a significant number of
new victims say from a small canadian
town
scp-2774-a's infection rate can rise to
as high as 60 percent or beyond the
residents of harper ridge made their own
predator deadlier without even knowing
it at a nearby foundation facility units
were already mobilizing it was too late
for those who had already seen the
slow-burned sloth but others could
potentially be saved if the situation
was contained quickly in addition to the
web crawler constantly monitoring the
internet the scp foundation also had a
huge number of dedicated teams scanning
broadcasts worldwide for potential
instances of scp-2774-a
exposure when one of these teams
detected the sloth's presence in
harper's ridge's morning newscast and
found that upwards of 4 000 civilians
had already been exposed they knew there
was no time to waste back in harper
ridge the situation was already
deteriorating a few hours had passed
since the broadcast and those who were
exposed were beginning to experience
strange symptoms already first it was a
sense of tiredness and lethargy then an
unusual heaviness to their body as
though they were experiencing sudden
extreme muscle fatigue people exposed to
scp-2774-also experienced clouded
cognition even thinking straight became
a real struggle it was at this point
that the true effects of witnessing the
slow burn sloth began to take hold
around six hours after initial exposure
little by little the infected lost all
cognitive functions and higher level
decision-making abilities their bodies
still acted out basic movements very
slowly seemingly just as a result of
muscle memory but they had no control
over what was going on they became
essentially living zombies trapped in
their own bodies and only dimly aware of
it this horrifying experience was
completely consistent with prior
foundation research into the effects of
viewing scp-2774-a
and in a twist almost crueler than
permanent zombification victims of the
slow burn sloth are randomly allocated
around 150 seconds of lucidity every 24
hours before being forced back into
their zombified state just as 4 000 of
harper ridge's residents were beginning
to experience these effects all local
communication channels to the town were
cut off by the foundation well-equipped
teams of mobile task force operators
began arriving on the scene shortly
after accompanied by a number of
containment units in the form of buses
and trucks lucky for them the zombified
victims of the slow-burned sloth were
incredibly docile and compliant by
nature shepherding all 4 000 of them
into the containment units were almost
like working with cattle some
non-infected local residents attempted
to protest the sudden abduction of their
zombified loved ones these residents
were subdued and either had their
memories wiped with foundation amnestics
or were terminated on site like with
almost any conceivable situation the scp
foundation already had measures in place
for a mass exposure event like this all
in all a mere 4000 was still on the low
end of the potential infection scale the
four thousand victims were secretly
taken to site 116 a foundation testing
site under the direction of dr martin
and his second in command dr clara chang
there they'd already been pursuing
research on approximately 2 400 infected
subjects from prior incidents including
foundation personnel who were
accidentally infected during the
monitoring process thus far it seemed
that the condition caused by witnessing
the slow burn sloth was incurable and
with 6400 known living victims situated
at site 116
scp-2774-a was at an unprecedented level
of power all site personnel were
instructed to proceed with caution and
carefully observed the behavior of their
new test subjects dr chong spearheaded
the majority of the hands-on research
into the infected residents of harper
ridge and observed some interesting
phenomenon in the victims behavioral
patterns as the condition escalated the
infected subjects even in their largely
zombified state developed an almost
fanatically religious obsession with the
image of the slow-burned sloth when left
to their own devices they would create
idols of scp-2774-a
these included amateur sculptures made
of hoarded garbage images drawn of the
sloth with any materials they could get
their hands on or even writing
obsessively about the sloth dr chung
speculated that this behavior was
perhaps an act of appeasement on the
victim's part hoping to somehow save the
slow burn sloth and lessen its effects
on them through worship however she
would later find out that the truth of
the matter was far more disturbing
initially due to their largely docile
states the subjects imprisoned in site
116 were given a relatively long leash
the subjects were even allocated two
hours a day for social interaction with
fellow subjects at meal times and during
a designated recreational period during
these times the subjects would often
trade their slow burn sloth effigies
with one another however dr chung
revoked the social interaction periods
and began confining the subjects to
separate euclid-class containment cells
when violence began to break out between
them it became clear that during their
150 second periods of lucidity every 24
hours the subjects would become
extremely distressed agitated and even
aggressive dr chung also ordered any
idols from trash sculptures to doodles
and notes on fragmented scraps of paper
to be destroyed immediately at its new
increased power the foundation became
concerned that
scp-2774-8 may develop the power to
manifest through these images no
meaningful headway was being made on a
cure for the condition so something
needed to be done before the situation
got out of hand in hopes of gaining a
better understanding of the internal
processes of slow-burned sloth victims
dr chung decided to conduct a series of
interviews with the subjects under her
care two such subjects subject zero
eight six six aka david and subject 7444
aka claire were isolated for a 24 hour
period in hopes of catching them during
their daily 150 seconds of lucidity dr
chung and the foundation found the
results of these two interviews to be as
illuminating as they were utterly
terrifying when david regained lucidity
he was in a state of extreme agitation
and showed an unsettling fixation on the
clock in the site 116 interview room
under direct questioning from dr chung
he revealed that slow burn sloth victims
are fully aware of what's happening
during their zombified periods he
compared the sensation to being a
passenger trapped and bound in a vehicle
over which they have no control however
in this state victims are also unable to
hold a thought consistently for longer
than five seconds
this leaves them in an almost constant
state of disorientation worse still
david describes that victims are
subjected to near-constant
hallucinations of the original sloth
image guiding and controlling their
movements almost like a puppeteer thanks
to the clock david was aware of when his
150 seconds of lucidity were about to
come to an end after apologizing for
what he was about to do david lunged at
dr chung causing a guard present in the
interview room to shoot him dead for dr
chung's protection dr chung's interview
with claire echoed the same sentiment
during her 150 seconds of lucidity
claire first begged to be killed before
divulging further details about the
zombification state she would describe
hallucinations of the burn sloth
stalking her constantly and controlling
her movements in some cases the sloth
would force her to open her eyes all
night while it stands next to her bed
and screams at her as claire's 150
seconds of lucidity ended and she became
non-responsive dr chung put in a request
for claire's termination a request that
was fulfilled three days later the third
interview with subject 9225
also known as jason showed that
scp-2774-8
appeared to be manually starting the
fights between the subjects perhaps even
for its own sadistic amusement he also
stated before the interview's conclusion
that the image of the sloth in his
hallucinations was becoming darker and
more tangible almost like it was
becoming a real physical being which was
an unprecedented phenomenon dr chung was
for the first time in a while truly
afraid it seemed by all accounts that
scp-2774-a's power was growing
considerably as a result of its huge
number of active victims its infection
rate had likely risen well above 40
percent and its ability to manifest
would likely be on the rise too if the
slow burn sloth was able to manifest on
a national broadcast millions would be
infected to truly apocalyptic results dr
chung only saw one solution that might
curtail the entity's growing power but
it wouldn't be pretty she devised a
procedure known as procedure
xxj9 as part of the procedure additional
staff were brought into site 116
immediately the real purpose of the plan
was revealed shortly afterward to reduce
the number of active subjects on site
from 6 400 to a mere 200 in hopes of
reducing risk over the next several days
staff at site 116 engaged in the
gruesome task of executing around 6 200
infected subjects via lethal injection
this was an atrocity so horrific even by
scp foundation standards that dr chung
allowed the parties involved to use
class a amnestics to erase their
memories of being involved in the mass
murder of site 116 subjects in the
aftermath of the call the foundation did
report a decrease in
scp-2774-a's manifestations so dr
chung's procedure did indeed work just
at a heavy human toll the tragic
incident of the 2010 harper ridge
scp-2774 containment breach is a grim
reminder of just how far the scp
foundation is willing to go to do their
job and a reminder to be careful where
you look because some images have a much
more lasting impact than others now go
check out scp-5049 this skin salesman
demon dan's discount homunculus depot
and the secret at the bottom of scp-087
explain for more frightening anomalous
horrors from the scp foundation